[Music]
jim's kicking off this hour in des
moines jim welcome to the ramsay show
yes thank you
how can i help today
[Music]
jim uh george i have uh i'm 63 years old
i i can see 64 in the uh in the very
near horizon i've been practicing law
for 35 years my wife and i make a
combination of about 190 000 per year
we have a one a house that the real
estate sites tell us is valued about 1.3
million which is i believe pretty
accurate um we have a 390 000 first ed
trust on that house and a
about 85 000 second mortgage on that
house we have four hundred and ten
thousand dollars in uh
non-raw iras combined between the two of
us
we have um another 440 000 in in regular
investment accounts
both are down a little bit right now as
you might imagine but uh
that's about what they are that's what
they were last friday um i um
have six children that i put through
catholic school from kindergarten
through
to senior year in college um 102 years
of catholic education and i paid the
tuition the whole way through wow so i
now have yeah um
102 years of education yeah they're all
six have bachelor's degrees a couple of
masters daddy paid for almost all of it
happy to do so
it was 1.2 million from the time my
oldest daughter is now 36 years old
started at college to the point my
youngest son graduated from which was
last may
i have come up with about six hundred
thousand in my own money and i have
about six hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in parent plus loans right now
[Laughter]
and uh you know they they have been very
good about saying you want to defer do
you want to hold held off they were
covered pauses um
but i think that i think that the
party's about to come to an end there
and uh i'm just wanting i i'm not
without some assets as i just described
to you i'm just wondering what you think
i should do
these these people navion and the
student loan people seem to be pretty
willing to to negotiate work out payment
plans um but it'll probably be the rest
of my life um
uh
all right all right i think i think i
think you got my story so uh
wow well uh you've done really well i
mean you guys have a great income you've
been investing but you also took on the
burden of six kids higher education and
so
what i want to do is is show you a path
to get out of this i'm sure
it was it was from kindergarten to
through college oh my god just higher
education it was it was lower middle and
in college 102 years private catholic
school the whole way
yep every every every step of the way
yeah was it worth it anyway
i'm sorry for your number
well
i think the answer is yes but uh i'm
still six hundred thousand dollars away
probably from answering the question uh
uh fully and honestly yeah
now what's the agreement with the kids
did you just say hey kids i got this
or do they feel like they should pay
some of this back
good question um the agreement was all
my kids went to very good
and expensive schools and i told them if
they
got to get in and they worked hard and
took it seriously
that that i would pay for it and all six
of them took me up on that deal and all
six have kept there in the bargain so it
is my hope to be able to just ride this
thing throughout myself
so there's no agreement that the kids
would
pay back um
if i think i got in too much trouble i
think it probably would i mean all six
are gainfully employed now all six are
doing well but they're all they're all
starting their lives now the grandkids
are coming they're buying houses they're
starting their their they're getting
married things like that okay well how
about this let's walk through the math
here uh how much do you have a
non-retirement you said you had 440 in a
general investing account
yeah i have i have a general investment
account primarily in
mutual funds and some individual stocks
of
right about 440 000 right now which is
down from about 500 000 a couple months
ago yeah late 2012 how much other cash
do you have in savings checkings all
that just non-retirement funds
non-retirement about another 35 000 in
cash okay so we're talking you have
about 470 of liquid cash
correct
now at your age you can touch the
retirement accounts i i'm trying to
avoid that before we do
but you need these payments out of your
life if you ever plan on retiring are
you still working if i ever plan
i am but like i said i'm i'm burning i'm
burning out on that as well so yes i've
been working 90 hour weeks for 35 years
and i need to break goodness
jim well
man you you uh you're not scared of work
but you've also taken on a lot of burden
for the family
yes and i'm happy to do it i'm not
complaining i'm just trying to find the
easiest exit ramp here i guess okay well
in the in the few minutes we have
remaining here's what i want to walk
through if you sold off all of the
investment funds that are non-retirement
you'd be down to
less than 200 000 dollars of student
loan debt
uh
20 and minus four four in round in very
round numbers yes i'd be about right
okay and then how quickly making 190 000
a year could we knock out the student
loans the remaining two hundred thousand
ah
two years if you hustled yeah at least
i'd have to hustle and have to have to
eat a lot of peanut butter sandwiches
but yes and then worst case could you
downsize and home if all the kids are
gone well that yeah we live in a 6500
square foot home
uh
we're empty nesters now there are rooms
we don't go into for months at a time so
yes
and from that deal if you sold it you
would net almost a million dollars
about 800 and something yeah okay yes so
to me that sounds like a better plan so
this is what i i have some peace just
listening this through if you sold off
the non-retirement funds leaving you
with about 200 000 you hustle to work
another two years to pay this all down
while your retirement keeps growing
and then you downsize and house and pay
cash for the next one leaving you with
no payments and a bunch of money sitting
in retirement
how's that sit with you
well
know that 440 000 provides me with some
level of security and uh you're not
secure jim you owe 620 000 to navient
that's no security
all right you can't bankrupt on that i
mean student loans are one of the most
difficult loans to get rid of what are
the payments on 620 000 of student loan
debt i'm just curious
about 4 000 a month right now okay now
walk this out with me in two years the
student loan payments are gone you now
have four hundred four thousand dollars
a month back in your life that you are
paying towards navient
now invest that even for ten years
at fifty grand a year you're going to be
okay in retirement but as long as these
student loans are chaining you down
you're never going to be able to retire
and so don't get started-eyed with the
investment accounts and you're doing
some fancy math over here dude you've
got to get these payments out of your
life you took on the burden and you can
get out with this income and retire with
dignity before you're 65 if i can help
it that's my plan for you jim rooting
for you man this is the ramsey show